I am jazzy 96 how do we communicate with
people who are difficult to work with
when we have to ooh what do you think
well yeah that's didn't out this lady's
like behavior so I told you this and I
guess I am jazzy it sounds like it's an
environment with customers I'll be
honest I've I never find them harder
communicate especially talk about social
media it sounds like when you get in the
situation it might not be few guys but
if you've got a relationship that's a
bit prickly with your boss or something
like that there matt is a position can
be a bit feisty so I think it comes back
to some of the basics haven't touched on
is number one we kind of have to put a
hot ass down at the center of the
conversation and put ourselves in their
shoes and then ask ourselves you know
what is it they want and why they kind
of behave in the way they are because
normally you know things are pretty
logical and then the other thing does
some are you know touching on the look
sort of April psychology stuff is in
reality is the beauty of the world is
everybody's got a different personality
and the reality is different personality
types some get on with each other some
want to go to a blue James game you know
all the time and they want to hang out
and repair some people don't want to do
that some people want to listen to music
some people to read books and therefore
you know I just think we've got to
accept the one of the beauties in life
is we're totally different and I think
the tolerance of that is definitely good
now if it will get on top you know I
think that there's loads of stuff you
can do in terms of you go to a mentor
art someone sort of independent kind of
[ __ ] happen in this situation it
could be with a customer could be with
one of your work colleagues from the
word skier as an entrepreneur and you
know particularly if you're an
entrepreneur and you're asking someone
in the tent of these something and it's
kind of not landing or its poor quality
or the letting customers down you know I
can understand that hurt and then
because you know what we said support
you know it's very personal you guys
sacrifices like you worked on our if the
few dreams and you want everybody to
pull the same level of weak as you do in
terms of you know that idea that you're
trying to get to market so if there's
other ways to help sighs go for some
mentorship and then ultimately if you
kind of work out what what is what is
the kind of clock that's ticking within
the person that's been challenging I'd
always advocate being honest with people
and say you know I don't think there's
anything is that someone summer taught
me once you know there's probably no bad
people around it's just sometimes the
behaviors really upset us and I think if
you sat down with someone's they look
you know person for whatever reason kind
of went off and on I kind of think
broadly we want the same things I want
to build this company I want to I want
to be the next Google I want everybody
under company to to follow the stream
let's be honest with each other what is
not clicking what's my work because you
know I'm not perfect I think this is
where you can use a bit sort of
self-deprecation ensure a bit of
vulnerability I'm not perfect but you
know what it did this kind of getting in
the way it because we want the same
things but we're bumping into each other
so what can we do to just you know
surface as they say in Canada get a
moose on the table get that moved on the
table and then we we can break it into a
thousand pieces and we can consume it
until they have to move on yeah I don't
know ever now did there it is again
that's that customization to the
audience i love it i mean i agree with
everything Stephen scene I almost want
to just kind of copy and paste and like
I would encourage you guys to watch that
clip back again those three points and
me we're really good you don't think i
would add to it is i go into every
situation trying to take full
responsibility and I think if you
advocate responsibilities when you start
to lose in all situations but here as an
example as soon as you label somebody
difficult you're saying it's their fault
right it's their problem they're the one
who's hard to deal with their difficult
and that reduces some of the
responsibility on me
you to navigate the situation where if
you just play back that last piece even
was talking about is that everyone is a
human being there's no bad people they
just have different circumstances
different upbringing different values
and if you take the responsibility to
say I want to navigate this I want to
make it a success put on yourself to
figure it out then just going in without
different mindset of thinking really
help you have more success in the
conversation on top of everything else
you've been talked about getting the
mentor trying to understand them put
yourself in their shoes it's really
great see I think I might have to watch
back that answer too i'm going to
bookmark that one I like that one it was
really good